there's no doubt about it How to Train
Your Dragon 3 the hidden world was one
epic movie but the ending was kind of
devastating thanks to fan theories and
headcanons we can now imagine a whole
new ending
check out these theories about what
happens to hiccup and toothless after
the third film get yourselves in one of
these days not everyone appreciates this
way of life How to Train Your Dragon 3
the hidden world hit us right in the
fields between all the action was a
story about friendship growing up and
letting go hiccup realise that the world
is just not ready to live with Dragons
the Magnificent beasts are still seen as
monsters to most Vikings toothless and
his girlfriend light fury discovered the
hidden world
hiccup plan to move all of Berk and
their dragons there but he soon realized
that wasn't the best plan humans don't
belong in the hidden world and the
Dragons will never truly be safe unless
they are hidden hiccup makes the
decision to let the dragons go the
goodbye scene between the Vikings and
the Dragons was so sad even though we
know it was for the best we didn't want
it to happen after toothless leads the
other dragons to the hidden world hiccup
and Astrid are finally ready to get
married he fully accepts his
responsibilities as chief of birth the
final scene takes place a few years
later hiccup has a beard and two
children he and Astrid take a boat with
their kids to the waterfall that guards
the hidden world toothless and the light
fury are perched on rocks with their
three baby dragons at first we aren't
sure of toothless remembers hiccup but
he does they reunite and we start crying
all over again asters dragons stormfly
also shows up Astrid and hiccup get to
ride their pets one less time and they
show their children how awesome dragons
are hiccup talks about the importance of
guarding the secret of the dragons until
the world is ready for them but what if
that isn't the end of the story let's
take a look at some theories and
headcanons about what happens after the
movie family vacations the first theory
is definitely a realistic option hiccup
obviously remembers how to get to the
hidden world in the final scene of the
movie his children are both really young
hiccup and aster have obviously had
their hands full for a few years but now
the kids are old enough for a trip to
meet the dragons so this theory suggests
that the trip we see is the first of
many we know from the third movie that
the hidden world isn't that far away and
Vikings are used to selling on the cold
sieze as long as the whole fleet from
Berk isn't going to the edge of the
world
the dragons are safe no one is going to
track hiccup someone little boats
why can't hiccup and his family go to
visit them all the time hiccup and
toothless are best friends once hiccup
is sure that toothless is still there
and remembers him he would definitely
want to come back he can see his best
friend every year if he wants it's not
too far-fetched of a theory some
families visit Grandma and Grandpa every
year other families go to Disney World
so hiccup and Astrid can definitely head
to the hidden world to visit their
dragons - toothless and stormfly are
practically family anyways hiccups kids
can grow up learning to ride dragons
toothless will teach his little dragons
that hiccup and Astrid are some of the
good humans the other residents of Berk
probably missed their dragons a lot - we
bet the people of Berk allowed to take
road trips we mean boat trips Drago
what fist does anything you say makes
sense the next generation we weren't the
only ones who wished for a happier
ending
there's a whole reddit thread dedicated
to alternate endings for hiccup
toothless and the rest of Berk one
theory has a lot to do with hiccups kids
there is no doubt that hiccup and Astrid
children would be amazing people Astrid
is tough brilliant and kind she's loyal
and brave hiccup is smart he's a great
leader and thinks outside of the box he
isn't afraid to take risks and he always
does what's right they will be great
parents and they will raise their kids
to be awesome Vikings it's obvious from
the last scene of the third movie that
the kids love to the Dragons they were
terrified at first but they soon
realized that there was nothing to be
scared about hiccup and Astrid take them
flying this would definitely be one of
the most important moments of their
childhood in the movie hiccup has
several flashbacks of his father talking
about the hidden world it stays with him
forever and that's how he saves the
Dragons maybe this is foreshadowing if
he gives his children an experience that
stays with them like his father's story
they might go on to do great things
reddit user halt 1776 suggests that
astronaut stilled Rijn ride the children
of toothless they become Dragon Riders
and trainers in their own right
with astron hiccups combined traits they
are able to finally bring peace to the
world together they're much stronger
leaders and their father was they can
carry on his legacy dragons can re-enter
the human world safely we love this
theory then dragons and humans could
coexist again and we love
the idea that hiccups kids turn out even
better than he did after all hiccups
father stoic was a great leader but
hiccup is even better
dark theories all right we know not
everyone loves a happy ending the ending
of How to Train Your Dragon 3 may not
have been the happiest way to end the
franchise but it did tie everything up
nicely and all the Vikings and Dragons
got to live happily ever after
even though they weren't together reddit
user halt 1776 came up with a few dark
theories for what happens after the
movies the first dark theory is a pretty
sad one hiccup says it's up to the
people of Berk to keep the secret of the
dragons and the hidden world but now
that Berk has no dragons they're just a
regular Viking village and hiccup isn't
the warrior his father was he did all
his fighting with dragons Vikings are
warriors by nature just because the
dragons are gone doesn't mean they'll
all live in peace there are probably
bigger stronger Viking villages there
are also conquerors from other parts of
the world if they decide to conquer Berk
kannberg survive what if they can't if
Burke gets wiped out the secret of the
Dragons will be lost forever whoa that's
a scary thought the next dark theory has
to do with night and light Furies we
know that toothless is the last night
fury
thanks a lot Drago and it seems that is
mate is the last light fury they
reproduce but that's not enough to carry
on a species or a breed the fury breed
of Dragons will die up once toothless is
kids are gone we don't know how long
dragons live in the world of How to
Train Your Dragon but eventually there
will be no more Furies they might mate
with other breeds of dragons and create
new mix dragons but either way the fury
species will be lost forever
the last dark theory is super sad we
don't know how we feel about this one
but if hiccup goes a long time without
seeing toothless again toothless could
forget him he's an animal after all sure
he's smart but once wild animals are in
their natural environments again they
stop trusting humans this could
definitely happen with dragons they
could basically return to their roots of
being scared of humans since they've
been without them for so long it's a
possibility
let's hope hiccup keeps visiting
toothless instead it's not so much what
you look like it's what's inside that he
can't stand a new chief and How to Train
Your Dragon 2
stoic was ready to retire he decided to
pass on his role as sheep to his son
hiccup problem was hiccup did not want
to be chief of Berk because well he
didn't know who he was yet he didn't
think he was a leader
although he knew better after stoical
dies hiccup has no choice to rule he
becomes chief and leads his people and
their dragons and he's great at it but
let's not forget that being chief is
never what he wanted throughout high
trainer dragon three copper is nagging
him to take on the rest of his
responsibilities as chief hiccup is
focusing on rescuing dragons instead
this headcanon comes from reddit user
ultrasonics one he says that hiccup
might decide to give the role of the
chief to someone else we definitely
believe this is something hiccup would
do he takes on his role as chief well
but he would get bored hiccup was made
to be an adventurer an inventor and a
dragon writer it's in his blood settling
down and dealing with the boring daily
demand for the village is so not hiccup
the original poster for this idea
suggested that dagger would be a great
option whose dagger well he wasn't in
the movies dagger the deranged is from
DreamWorks dragons the series dagger was
hiccups arch-nemesis turned a lie in the
show he is the chief of the Berserker
tribe they form an alliance with birth
if hiccup continued to form alliances
these tribes could merge if not there
are some decent chief options on Berk
eret would be a great leader he's a
great warrior he's brave and kind and
he's also really smart
hiccup would definitely trust him the
rest of this theory suggests that hiccup
runs off and moves his family to the
hidden world we bet he would bring his
mom Valka along - she loves dragons just
as much as him after all
hiccup and Valka are totally meant to
live among dragons this is definitely a
believable theory retirement okay so
maybe hiccup wouldn't want to be a chi
for very long but maybe he actually
enjoys it once the dragons are safe he
doesn't have to spend all his time
worrying about saving them he can focus
on his people with way less stress this
is another theory from halt 1776 on
reddit let's imagine that hiccup leads
Berk for a long time just like his dad
we know that Chiefs can retire from the
second movie once hiccups kids are old
enough to rule he can retire he and
Astrid get old and are ready to move on
well for teacup do when she retires well
he might not have much keeping him in
birth and he said goodbye to his best
friend a long time ago Ashford was also
really close to stormfly we kind of
loved the idea that this power couple
retires to the hidden world they would
love to spend their golden years among
all the dragons plus their kids know
where to find them they can still come
to visit lots of people like to move to
fun destinations once they retire
why should hiccup an asteroid be any
different we bet toothless would be
thrilled to see them we wonder if
toothless will have retired as alpha and
pass a troll on to one of his kids he
always had a lot in common with hiccup
you know Oh buddy his fist with my face
if he tries to take my dragon the future
hiccup made a big deal of saying that
the world wasn't ready for dragons yet
lots of people took this to mean that
there would be a sequel we aren't sure
about that but we like to imagine that
one day the world will be ready for
dragons
so does reddit user rocket the raccoon
they posed the idea that Dragons stay
hidden until modern day then there is a
new hero who befriends a dragon and the
world is finally ready to live in peace
with them this theory might not have to
do with toothless and hiccup but it's
still awesome to think about how would
our world be if there were dragons can
we get our hands on an adorable Night
Fury How to Train Your Dragon is based
on a series of books by Cressida Cowell
there are 12 books in the series they
aren't exactly like the movies but the
ending is similar hiccup has the dragons
go into hibernation since the world is
not ready for them they convince the
world that dragons were a myth Cressida
Cowell intended for the books to be an
alternative history the story takes
place in the real Viking world and is
the reason dragons don't exist anymore
if the books are anything to go by we
won't get another movie but we can still
pretend that something happens after the
final scene which of these theories
about hiccup and toothless do you choose
to believe let us know in the comments
give this video a big thumbs up if you
think hiccup and toothless our
friendship goals for more fun Theory
videos about your favorite fandoms
subscribe to the things thanks for
watching and see you next time
[Music]